all right man we're in the Bay area
right now in an undisclosed location
with my guy burner he's got this [__]
place he's been working how many years
two years you been working on this place
yeah two years what are we about to walk
into the compound you're the first
person actually see it to I haven't
really showed this [__] off at all all
right well listen no one's ever seen
this I'm excited to see it we're about
to go into the cookies compound come on
got to have that little highte you know
technology the door you know no keys No
ke push the start you know what I mean
push the start this is like our holding
Lounge right here you know when people
come we need to decide which sector of
the building they're going to go to they
could be held right here we got a pool
table coming right here you got a
kitchen in there that would be full of
snacks and all kind of good stuff kind
of feels like a shady strip club I know
I like it you know just missing the pole
just missing the pole and a DJ that's
all kitchen here yeah kitchen it's
simple it's just more like for snacks
and stuff like that you know you can
wash your ditches heat up your food this
will also be a lounge for the you know
everything we're going to do in there so
once the warehouse is built out and
there's multiple TV sets stud giant
Warehouse over here that you're building
out that's C 7,000 ft crazy this is a
hallway to Hill it's playing it's a
hallway right here we got more pictures
coming kind of bring it to life if you
come to this building and you end up in
this room you're somebody important this
is like where the real big level
conversations happen you're a boss you
know what I mean got a bathroom got a
gym being built in here this is where
the cozy kitchen happens this is a state
of- art kitchen um this is a huge
[__] Hood the music is coming from
the hood right here we got two speakers
inside Hood I don't know anyone else
that got some player ass [__] like this
also this all custom one inone [__] you
see my name on the on the oven right
there man I always see the guy on
YouTube with this thing um Sam the
cooking guy yeah I need one of these you
can do anything on this sh you can make
fried rice you can make Kanye Sada you
can make whatever you want fish that
[__] hard and this is probably one of
the most expensive art pieces I've ever
bought it's like a crazy I don't even
know how to describe it but who's you
know Who's the artist Dustin yellen's
the artist So when you say this is the
most expensive art piece you ever bought
what does that cost all these go for
like 500 600,000 it's really crazy
there's a lot of hidden gems is you come
this way too all disappear you can see
if people who uh don't know you come
over here you can see the back it's kind
of like a bunch of layers yeah super
layered some trippy psychedelic art I
feel like if I was like I would want to
[__] do some LSD spray and just look
at this sh yeah yeah he doesn't make a
lot of these either and they're pretty
hard to get and this painting is crazy
too yeah that's how I felt the when the
guy made it he's like how do you feel
right now I'm like I just explained how
I felt and he painted it yeah wow so
what did you tell him how did you feel
at the time oh you can see it it's
turbulent it's rough times right now wow
but you know you'll make it to the top
you'll see you'll see the bright side of
life no matter what people trying to
pull me down but the Roses still rising
to the top know cancer just got aen up I
just ate cancer up this is the predatory
[__] [__] [__] [__] piece
of [__] [__] trying to take my
[__] from me right here plotting on this
[__] but the ship's going to make it
through the waves through the turbulent
times wow at the end of the day bro I'll
be on top and I guess that's me right
there so this is dope yeah so you
explain how you felt to somebody right
now and they just kind of they painted
it for me shout out to Who's the artist
sebilla
amazing yeah he's dop I wouldn't be the
we guy if I didn't have some cool custom
[__] like this this is my hash fridge
right here
got hash cool like a wine FR type
technology see logos on the side
somewhere I think it's some on these
sides but yeah player hash Ridge right
here you just got the the hash ready to
go and hash on Deck sick that's sick
custom cookies TV you just got a [__]
pound ready to go in here yeah this
actually is a human door keeps the keeps
the moisture content on point
but come on guys guys got cookies it
would only be
right can't be too far away from some of
that loud no the boardroom not fully
done yet but it's going to come together
so guys got to get marrow work together
in here what is this made of that
concrete slab solid BR little slab of
concrete painting of you and your mom
yeah got to keep you know what's real to
me in here of course man you know it's
definitely real to me two bathrooms I'm
going to turn this into a sauna right
here oh a sauna you got to have the cold
clunge in there yeah bedroom there just
a bedroom in here it's not made out yet
but I'm I'm going to make it a fly ass
bedroom so who's going to stay in here
just me when I want to take a nap I love
it I'll make
love [__] the Boom Boom Room boom boom
this feels like it's just like your
office on like just steroids yeah it's
like hey guys this is my office I have
11 kitchens you guys want to close a
multi-million dollar deal come sit down
with me come to my office please come to
my home yeah I would just live here
honestly all right up here we got like
the brains this is the main area for for
the building you got wait one two three
you got 10 offices right here who all
works out of here so right now right now
it's nobody so if you want to be on the
team come pull up we're looking for
creatives we're looking for editors just
on the content side of things so this is
going to be kind of just a Content hub
for you yeah the other table was
impressive this is much more impressive
it's custom if you look at the bottom
too see I see on the bottom I see I can
see it where it's at to the back you get
a table like this made what does that
cost you I didn't even ask this feels
like a $40,000 table yeah I probably is
I didn't honestly didn't even ask you
got a second kitchen up here for the
staff you know people upstairs we we
don't want them to have to leave they
can make their lunch in there we could
have a chef come and cook for them right
over here we have our showroom it's like
a baby dispo obviously nothing's for
sale just here to show what the new
strains are that we're featuring that
we're excited about so you have like a
mock cookies dispensary in the the
compound yeah this is like a little mini
if you've ever been into a cookies you
know so what's the thought process of
having the like the the storefront kind
of set up here well like if buyers come
and they want to look at new products
that we're featuring or we're trying to
lock in a new account they could come
here and look at the product in a much
more intimate way than like just showing
them turkey bags like yo this is what it
look like in your store this is how it
be merchandising your store California
lemonade huh California I see it's a
medicated drink this is our reception
area but also like I mean it's probably
one of my favorite chill areas like come
here and have good powerful calls right
here so the chairs are these chairs are
[__] fire super dope perceptions will
be there yeah yep so when people enter
the building they'll enter right here
first the first thing you see you go
right to the media area you can go left
to the brains of the business or if
you're a boss to go downstairs to I'm at
this is our editing Bay we have our
editors in here usually working just on
all the content you see tour Recaps
blogs cooking content stuff like
that M I love the briskness in here
smells great in here boys this is our
podcast room we just did a podcast here
we just did a podcast in here it's fully
set up you can edit live this where we
do all the inside the bag stuff and
stuff like that so when you do the
inside the bag [__] that that the theme
of that show is essentially like popping
seeds going through new strains just
like seeing all our R&D stuff like what
we find from different genetics that we'
be looking at and stuff like that are
you still planning like a like a 100
years ahead of time of like strains hell
yeah cuz I know we talked and you were
like yo when I'm gone I want strains to
like come out the Vault yeah I don't
want people just to let let this [__]
die got have that heat yeah the goal is
this is going to be like the brains of
my business I want all design marketing
and content curated right here I just
wanted to be here with me I like it you
know what I mean this is shows popping
the podcast room you know take a seat on
the couch Kev these these couches aren't
cheap you know I don't think they
are that's a good couch it's butter it's
butter no will have hemorrhoid working
here dude they're have they're good you
have high level Furniture taste yeah I
love it man you know you could Al also
film a parno in here if all goes work I
can [__] you could get back to your old
school days and have chicks hit [__]
pens with their [__] that was a video
right I'm not yeah she was Asian I think
God bless her I wonder what she's doing
she's trying to come
back there we have it that's a compound
a lot of new content coming and the
youall didn't see the warehouse spot the
warehouse is just this empty Blank Slate
of I mean you're going to be built the
sets you're yeah it's my it's my baby
Tyler Perry what coming soon man well I
appreciate the tour brother go watch our
new uh interview that just dropped we
got the exclusive First Look cookies the
compound sleep baby don't sleep
[Music]
boom